was ich heute fordern werde ist ein
volksaufstand gegen google amazon
facebook und co wir reden alle vom
künftigen klimakollaps und sonstigen
gefahren die in ferner zukunft liegen
und schauen daran vorbei dass wir längst
opfer einer ktm einer katastrophe sind
die jetzt im moment stattfindet und die
nicht in ferner zukunft stattfindet
sondern hier und jetzt sie sind opfer
der sogenannten zur balance economy
einer neuen wirtschaftsordnung die
darauf hinausläuft die darauf basiert
uns auszuleuchten uns auszuspionieren
und und süchtig zu machen facebooks
mutterkonzern meter hatten heute
angekündigt dass sie damit mit den
genannten spielen sich aus europa
zurückzuziehen
das klang für mich und war der grund war
dass die datenschutz vorgaben der eu zu
streng sein für mich ist die warnung von
facebook und instagram sich aus europa
zurückzuziehen etwa so bedrohlich als ob
das
sinaloa-kartell in mexiko damit droht
sich aus dem europa passen kokain
geschäft in europa zurückzuziehen ich
fordere dass wir endlich aufwachen
hier läuft gründlich was schief diese
konzerne sind viel zu mächtig sie
spionieren uns aus sie verdienen für die
verdienen ihr geld mit unseren daten und
wir haben jetzt diese digitale
revolution geht es erst seit 20 jahren
ist doch relativ normal dass man erst
spät da dahinter kommt was für macht was
für macht dort gewalt ist und ich hoffe
auf feste unterstützung von herrn
bartsch auch riesig diese konzerne zu
zerschlagen oder zumindest so stark zu
reglementieren dass wir dem einen stopp
setzen in der senne gefahr die jetzt
aktuell stattfindet und nicht irgendwie
ferner zu tun
solche media gerade denke ich als junge
junge leute aber sonst ja immer mehr
ältere auch wenn ich da auf facebook
sehen nicht nur die natur an sich jetzt
also es ist so essenziell ehrlich gesagt
auch für politische kommunikation
wenn es wer schaut heutzutage doch auf
eine homepage ja es läuft alles über
facebook instagram wie man sich
repräsentiert öffentlichkeitsarbeit und
da ist natürlich dann die frage ist
nicht so weit fortgeschritten dass wir
davon tatsächlich abhängig sind also
genau die these und wie wir es genau das
ist die frage ich denke in einigen also
wir können uns um wandern wir können
dann auf andere wenn jetzt facebook
nicht mehr in europa wäre finden wir
andere möglichkeiten das ist keine frage
nur die frage ist wie sehr sind wir
abhängig und wollen überhaupt dass
facebook beispielsweise das feuer gab es
wieder die fahrt durch jetzt eine sache
natürlich natürlich um noch mal zum
vergleich zu leben mediziner
sinaloa-kartell zurückzukommen natürlich
sind die big pack konzerne keine
verbrecherorganisationen aber was man
nicht oft genug wiederholen kann weil
das wenige leute wissen bei der
entstehung war der entwicklung von apps
wie instagram oder tik tok wurden
neurowissenschaftler in die in die
entwicklung mit einbezogen mit dem
gezielten mit den gezielten absicht die
app so zu entwickeln dass sie süchtig
machen indem sie unser dopamin haushalt
im gehirn
manipulieren und ich möchte den
vergleich zu kokain tatsächlich noch mal
ernsthaft wiederholen als wo als vor 100
jahren kokain auf den markt kam konnte
bekam er das freien apotheke macht das
zum teil gegen hornhaut beschwerden und
gegen heuschnupfen eingesetzt erst
später ist man dahinter gekommen dass es
eben süchtig macht wir sind jetzt in dem
zeitpunkt dass wir sehen dass diese das
nicht nur diese konzerne unglaublich
räuberisch mit unseren daten umgehen
sondern dass sie gezielt von anfang an
so konzipiert waren dass die junge leute
süchtig machen ich war neulich eine
ausstellung von einem voller von einem
fotografen harald hauswald dem sie
wahrscheinlich kennen der bar einer der
gründer von ostkreuz da hat mich ich bin
fast sicher ich habe das gemacht so
fotos aus berlin der 80er jahre im
und was man dort sieht kinder die auf
der straße spielen der eine hatten für
holz holz schwert in der hand der
anhalten kaputtes fahrrad das sieht man
heute gar nicht mehr ich bin mit meinem
sohn am strand den lang gegangen blickt
mich rum der hat ihn so häufig dann
musste er selber lachen wir schaffen
natürlich macht das süchtig und geber
kokain wo man auch erst 20 30 40 jahre
darauf reagiert hat müssen wir diese
gefahr jetzt langsam ernst nehmen wer
erwachsen ist wächst eine generation
heran die gar nicht mehr die einen ein
autor das natürlich beschrieben es ist
so als ob wir ständig mit juckpulver
bestreut werden das müssen wir endlich
ernst nehmen und ich fordere euch und
habt ihr handys dabei eine app eurer
wahl musste abend zu löschen lange
nichts weiter an und werde jetzt heute
abend dort also hätten oder instagram
und ich werde
also ein
neues löschen snatch etwas tun was sie
denn alle social media also es läuft gut
entfernen
das problem ist ich habe jemanden jahren
so alles ganz und alle zuschauer auch
eine war er sie durch ist eine app aus
und löst eine app regionalen instagram
ich habe bist du sicher dass sensible
löschen es dinge step löschen der
account bleibt ja bestehen wenn man
ziemlich ist schonmal er wurde aber du
musst dich jetzt wieder einmal ein
lockerer so weiter ja aber richtig
schlüssig wirklich zu ich wollte nur
zwei bemerkungen dazu man erstens bei
kindern hält man diese entwicklung nicht
auf also die sind ja schon bevor sie in
die schule kommen auf ihn mit den
gestern eine kapitulation sondern ja
weiter eltern das über antworten dass
keine kapitulation dass eine
gesellschaft ist anders geworden auch
die kommunikation ist anders geworden
die lesen keine zeitungen mehr die
werden nie eine zeitung lesen und auch
keine zeitschrift die zeiten sind vorbei
die gehen alle kaputt sie sind an langen
aber ich glaube dass man erst wenn man
relativ erwachsen ist die größe im kopf
hat zu entscheiden was man da eigentlich
tut und dann zu entscheiden wo man
rausgeht und wo man drinbleibt und das
ist ich bin zum beispiel niemals bei
facebook mitglied geworden ich habe die
rauchen eingeschrieben raus aus facebook
habe ich immer für gefährlich gehalten
da bin ich noch gesteinigt worden ich
brauche facebook nicht für nichts
braucht doch sonst niemand und es hat
lange gedauert bis er habe beck und frau
merkel bei facebook ausgetreten sind
weil sie dann zu langsam erkannt haben
was das eigentlich für ein laden ist
facebook hat aber glaube ich seine hohe
zeit hinter sich da sinken inzwischen
wieder die abonnentenzahlen und es gibt
eine aber diese blieben kam er an sky
abonnenten zahlen weil die 20-jährigen
auf instagram und die 18-jährigen optik
davos hätte nicht besser
sagen dass auch schon mal so rog hat es
die leute die auf facebook zugreifen
die sind in einem alter über 40 geht das
los hat ihre starke ausbreitung 50
erhält so richtig ist instagram ist
tipptopp das sind die nummern und da
haben sie ja völlig recht ich meine ich
bin ja sehr dafür die konzerne zu
schlagen nur das schaffen wir beide
nicht aber die selbstwerber zu haben was
wir können was wir können und das ist
doch der rockefeller als auch geklappt
wie lange schlange jeder kann etwas tun
natürlich ist das erstens süchtig machen
das auszusprechen sagen was ist es
auszuschalten auszusprechen menschen zu
warnen und dann wird sich auch diese
erkenntnis natürlich verbreitern und
fest in der verständlichen zerschlagen
werden wie sie nicht das sind
ausgeklügelte mechanismen den wir im
übrigen auch alle zum opfer fallen und
in der politik im übrigen ist es ja so
da gibt es ja fast eine verpflichtung
das zu machen wer auf keinem netzwerk
ist die will ich mal sehen also ich
misstraue von metternich
was haben sie denn gewählt
das geht ja das zentrum
das kann ich noch nicht
nein aber ein ganz ganz wesentlicher
punkt wo man laut sagen muss was es
bedeutet und alle ja auch die großen
verlage es ist ja nicht so dass die
jetzt nicht bei twitter bei facebook bei
all diesen neuen plattformen sind
natürlich natürlich aber der eine punkt
einig dass an der stelle sagen kann
meine kolumne erscheint ausschließlich
in print und ich halte auch print uns
durch schön weil ich möchte nicht ich
möchte ich meine kolumne ist gemacht
fürs papier wenn sie es immer das
allerletzte was im bild erscheinen und
das funktioniert er im internet gar
nicht weil es gibt ja im internet nicht
das letzte wort kannst du immer weiter
scrollen das heißt manchmal erscheint
nur exklusive rind und ich muss sagen
ich halte auch diese ständige gerede
bringt ist vorbei und das ist das andere
ist die zukunft ich glaube dass das teil
eines augenleidens von diesem begriff
alten bewerben
sich danach sehnen physische bibliothek
zu gehen dort humanen kontakt zu machen
und nicht alles ständig über über suchen
und sich irgendwelche datei marge das
ist das werden was miteinander reden
miteinander quatschen und ich alles über
liebe das ist ja ich will nur einen
vorschlag machen lena wieder abwinkt und
mir das wort ab so also ich glaube das
ist schon lange überfällig ist das war
an den schulen medien unterrichtsfach
haben uns richtig überall wo die jungen
leute aufgeklärt werden darüber was sich
in den so wichtigen werken
sind womit ihr geld verdienen
auf dem zettel stehen so und drauf es
macht süchtig ich möchte dass bei
instagram und bei ticket vorher steht
ist süchtig und das den test ist
gespräche dass das die politiker auch
wenn sie uns ständig angst machen vor
irgendwelchen von irgendwelchen
erkrankungen die immer harmloser bergen
dass sie auch mal die angst vor die
angst vor der tat digitaler
verwahrlosung ernst genommen würden das
ist ein thema ist über das öffentlich
diskutiert wird und nicht einfach wie
herr jörges sagt haben das muss man
einfach so hinnehmen das könnte hätte
man bei kokain auch sarah